we have sound speed sound rolling ready
kirk okay roll picture
the smithsonian's national museum of
natural history has over 144 million
objects like this narwhal tusk
my name is kirk johnson i'm in charge of
all of them
99 of the collections are behind the
scenes and these are the people that
work with them
this is carla dove from the division of
birds
here in the division of birds we have
somewhere around 620 000 museum
specimens
and that represents about 85 percent of
the diversity of birds in the world you
look at these specimens and you realize
that this is where the science is really
going to start we're using our
collections to identify birds that
collide with airplanes and help us
improve aviation safety
dr bob robbins curator of butterflies
and moths i have been professionally
employed as a lepidopterist works on
butterflies for about 35 years this is
the essence of my being is to know
everything about butterflies there's a
whole
world out there that unless you look
very closely you don't see and it's an
interesting world it's a fascinating
world and it is full of practical value
for human beings
this is ellen strong curator of mollusks
what i love about this collection is its
breadth we estimate that we may have as
many as 20 million specimens
we are preserving a record of past life
on this planet of present life on this
planet and preserving that for the
future
i take that responsibility very
seriously in providing access and caring
for the specimens for posterity
dr jeff post curator of the national gem
and mineral collection
minerals in this collection go from
something that formed maybe in the last
few tens of years to others that formed
more than three billion years ago we
know right now there are more than 5 000
minerals that make up the earth and in
our collection we probably have more
than half of those each one's a little
piece of the puzzle and try to put all
these things together and hopefully
eventually understand the big picture of
how the earth works
and floyd shockley collection manager
for entomology
we have just a little over 35 million
specimens in the collection a third of
all insect life on earth is represented
by at least one specimen in our
collection when you look at a collection
the size of ours you're starting to get
to a point where you can ask really big
questions the questions related to
global climate change habitat
destruction and you can only answer
those big questions if you have a lot of
specimens collected over a long period
of time a lot of different species
to understand the earth and the living
things of the earth
you need to collect those things and
preserve them and study them
and that helps you when you need food or
when you have a disease all that stuff
arcs back the fact that we have samples
of the whole planet here and that's how
we understand the planet
[Music]
you